morning you guys well we've got a very
windy weekend ahead of us but it will
bring some cooler changes so if this
heat has just wilted you a little bit
this week the good news is you can relax
a little bit more but it may be tough to
be outdoors
once these winds really get started a
lot of 80s out there this morning and
we've got more heat coming our way high
clouds all being pulled up from the
south west coast
there could be a chance for some showers
and thunderstorms mainly to the north
and the east of us later today and into
Saturday otherwise we've got red flag
warnings just putting us on alert that
dry gusty winds for most areas today
will definitely put us in fire critical
fire weather conditions so please be
safe out there
103 well above the norm of mid 90s the
record for today's 109 out on the water
with a wind advisory also issued today
for the river in the Lake
those Whitecaps are going to be big
we're talking 35 maybe 40 mile-per-hour
winds
so we'll go from 103 with the system
past us tomorrow a nice cooling effect
down to 90 degrees on Saturday 86 on
Sunday still some strong winds tomorrow
breezy on Sunday and we start off the
week in the low 80s but we heat up very
quickly back to triple digits by
Thursday